foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
I'm Piers Morgan I'm censored tonight
campaigners from the guardian of course
where else demand the Manchester's two
famous football clubs ditched the ships
from their Crest because get this they
might represent slavery as The Purge of
woke history of History I'm sorry
reached Peak woke insanity
and not many Street parties coronation
stumps from top pop stars and the no
show from President Biden is the crown
losing its Sparkle under King Charles or
will our patriotic further return in
time we'll debate that
that's Ryanair Chief Michael O'Leary
says delusional brexiteers will die off
soon and then Britain will send station
rejoin the EU is he right
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored well
good evening everybody Welcome to Piers
Morgan uncensored and it really is
uncensored anyone who watched last
night's show could be under No Illusion
about just how uncensive we are Joseph
Stalin's murderous Soviet Union wrote
this Playbook on airbrushing history
after every treacherous Purge statues of
traitors were torn down roads were
renamed books were Rewritten Heroes
turned villains were even scrubbed from
photographs until one day it was bronzes
of a tiny dictator himself being toppled
and tossed into lakes over here in the
enlightened West we tended to do things
rather differently we learned from the
horrors of the past and use them to
build a better future but not anymore a
multi-year movement to rename schools
hospitals Parks pubs streets even entire
suburbs over the historic links to
slavery is reached in my opinion and now
hysterical conclusion cultural van
candles want and of course they're at
the Guardian newspaper where else would
they possibly be these woke waste rules
they want the crests on the badges for
Manchester City and Manchester United
two of the biggest clubs in Britain and
the world to be removed because of
course they're ships and therefore they
must represent racism and slavery
seriously
and in the irony of ironies the seeds of
this unhinged campaign as I said started
by the guardian this is the newspaper
which recently had to apologize because
it turned out their own Founders were
linked to transatlantic slavery so this
is a kind of guilt shaming from the
guilty party it's like a murderer
telling us not to murder people
there's nothing more sanctimonious than
the guardian in full sail for want of a
better analogy but should we really be
taking lectures from a newspaper which
has so disgraced itself with its own
horrific links to slavery he thinks not
been a self-flagellating 3000 word
lament the paper says the ship has
nothing to do with football and
everything to do with the business from
which Manchester made its money the
product of slavery became so subtly
embedded in our culture that we
celebrated it in our club badges without
even realizing it
and of course these crests absolutely do
not celebrate slavery the ship
represents the Manchester shipping Canal
free trade the Industrial Revolution The
two clubs were found in many decades
after slavery was outlawed by the
British Empire I might add
but the demented quest to stoke
grievance and Signal virtue stops at
nothing we must continue always to feel
ashamed about everything that's ever
happened and be responsible and pay for
it forever
and the century campaign to conflate
past and present is certainly everywhere
isn't it lawmakers in San Francisco have
held serious discussions about paying
every black adult in San Francisco 5
million dollars in reparations for
historic racism and the former BBC
journalist Laura trevelyn recently
donated a hundred thousand pounds to
Grenada where her ancestors once owned
slaves and she's quit the BBC to
campaign for more people including the
British royal family to do the same
just like the ridiculous Crusade against
historic symbols this movement blames
the evils of the past on the people of
today none of whom had anything to do
with it and most of whom I imagine
probably condemn it as much as anybody
else
we can learn a lot from the palings of
the past but first we must stop
destroying it and stop apologizing for
it well joining me now is the author and
playwright Bonnie Greer taught to be
contributor and lawyer or Ron Adrian and
the podcast host from across the pond
Hotel Jesus well welcome to all of you
um all right Paula
let's start with you because I know what
you're about to say is going to make me
infuriated and it's going to be utterly
insufferable excellent uh these are two
crests that carry images of sailboats
yes it's got nothing to do with slavery
or racism
if that's your opinion then you're
entitled to have it it's a fact well you
don't know that peers and the historians
are being asked to look into that and
that's what should properly happen
shouldn't it because when you tell us
about history and how important history
is what we want to do is to ensure that
we have got this right and we are going
to grow from this experience yeah I'm
not growing up I'm getting I'm going to
deny it I am growing from this
experience I'm growing very annoyed and
I'll tell you why why are we annoyed let
me tell you why weary let me tell you
what talk about slavery no no I'm not
worried about it I thought slavery
required I talked about World War one
and World War like everybody I know I
thought slavery was disgusting and I'm
very very glad that everyone came around
to their senses it was disgusting and
that Britain actually led the way in
ending the damn thing of course I do
slavery was disgusting
however
it turns out the historians say
Manchester didn't adopt ships as an
emblem until 1842. yes 35 years after
the abolition of slavery yes so they
would have had nothing to do with it and
how do we know that we don't know that
so what you are doing is you are taking
one understanding of a situation you're
believing the historians will suit your
narrative it's not what I believe peers
let's be clear about this we're having a
debate and that's what is important
about us to be able to have a debate
about something that happened in history
we shouldn't be looking at pictures of
little pictures of of ships on a
footballer's Crest bad who cares well
it's got nothing to do with this well
clearly I'm sure the players at
Manchester City and Manchester United
those who Advocate uh you know show
racism the red card no it's not gonna
happen they will care about it the
guardian which has just been caught with
its racism trousers down right because
it turned out they were founded by a
bunch of slave owners right so they're
the last people on Earth to be
utterly ridiculous I'll tell you why
well they've apologized every single
family in Britain if you go back far
enough you'll have people in their past
hundreds of years ago who employed
slaves almost certainly and therefore
and therefore we know that was wrong
then why should everybody today who had
nothing to do with it
spend their entire time apologizing for
it it's about education yes first of all
just education and the second thing it's
about you know this we always rewrite
history we wrote We rewrote World War II
because we found out about Bletchley we
didn't a person who grew up in the 50s
would have a different World War II than
a kid now because we found out about
bleachly so we are getting more
intelligent and that's one thing that's
happening
hang on and the other thing
the the United Kingdom was actually on
the side of the Confederacy during the
Civil War and in fact was going to send
a ship to the Confederacy to fight for
it when it was started
okay and paid an Indemnity who is going
to pay me yes and my family reparations
for what the Vikings did to us well I
think you should seek it out
what I'm saying is once you start this
woke Rampage there is no end a bit like
the statues of historical figures
they're all guess what hang on let me
finish ladies give me a moment all
historical figures are flawed you can
find flaws in Mandela in Gandhi and
Churchill that's why they had to be
boarded up their statues of parliament
Square so the mob didn't attack them yes
but if we take this route everything all
the time we have to be apologizing
paying for it why why
what's wrong with an apology nothing is
wrong with that if you I'm very sorry
the hundreds of years ago people blame
anything to do with hundreds of years we
acknowledge it we always do that that is
what history why should footballers have
to remove crests they contain images of
ships which according to many historians
were adopted as an emblem 35 years after
slavery was abolished well it was
abolished but it wasn't over okay and
that's
right no we don't know that but we need
them we need to investigate it why not
All Ships could be raised
all right
my general point is this I think slavery
was horrific I think if you basically
chart back from almost any family in
Britain and America you'll find some
evidence somewhere that someone in the
family probably was employed in in using
slave slavery when it was going on uh
but I just don't understand the point of
this constant series now of
recriminations reparations apologies
guilt trips and so on I don't know what
point it serves
I worked uh at a tech company once
and we know how Rife they are with
leftism and in casual conversation in
the office I said you know I want to be
a national master in chess one day
and this white girl said to me she said
don't you feel offended that they use
the term master
in the title
and I just looked at it like you know
that thought never crossed my mind the
same thing if I were to go to the harbor
and I would see a ship I would not think
of slavery right there's a huge
fascination with slavery amongst black
people where our educational system our
upbringing has tied us to this travesty
in human history
and made us want to identify with it
instead of identifying with richer parts
of our history now here's the issue that
this comes down to
um women are going to see the world
frankly different from men women are
very emotional so of course they're
going to be worried about you know
what's on the badge and all this stuff
when we look at the UK right the UK has
about
4 million Starving Children
right now and that doubled since the
past two years I love the hotel do you
think that children that are hungry care
about some badges they can't eat
football badges you know what leftism
does is they try to sidestep the real
dilemmas and worry about all these
Frills on the outside on the exterior
Hotel
apart from saying that you've made two
really good friends here with your women
get to emotional from the south side of
Chicago
and I'll let you three deal with that
after the show but really impressed I've
got two things to say to what you just
said one is there was a genuine debate
in Australia several years ago because
an academic went on the Airways and
claimed that chess which you just talked
about was racist because the white
pieces went first right and I remember
thinking at the time the only time
anyone in the world would think that
that was the case was if some academic
decided to pop his head up and go it's
racist nobody actually believes chess is
racist for that reason and secondly on
your second point about current things I
read today that there are between seven
and eight million slaves in India alone
at the moment now correct now if the
Guardian newspaper wants to launch a
campaign against slavery in India I'm
all in I'm all in for any current
slavery going on anywhere in the world I
will join that campaign but going back
several hundred years to a spurious
argument which turns out may not even be
historically correct about badges on
football players where they show ships
therefore All Ships are racist and
therefore they must be removed to me is
preposterous well they do the same thing
here in America they wanted to remove
Aunt Jemima from product packaging then
one is tear down statues they're tearing
down
um Lee uh Robert E Lee I believe his
name was famous that to happen brother a
whole bunch of people are involved in
what uh Jay-Z as a quote it goes moral
victories are for minor league coaches
when you really want to get into the
nitty-gritty of things you look at more
important issues than just badges on the
football uniform I just don't get it do
you know something uh you just use the
phrase nitty-gritty that itself has been
banned now no yes
I've seen people say that is a racist
term yeah yeah and historians
so you accepted these historians who pop
their head up saying all the stuff can
be because it's completely wrong first
of all I want to get your Collective
reaction to the suggestion that this is
really a female thing you women are a
little over emotional about that I've
never heard a man say that for a long
time right so that I think about an hour
what is your what is your response I
would like to ask him what he thought
about the um American football uh clubs
who have changed their names because
they referenced various members of of
society who didn't think that it was
appropriate that they should be
um called those names we have uh rugby
clubs who have changed their names
because they didn't think that it was an
approach we're not talking about we're
not talking about potentially or
inflammatory names which have evolved
over the years we're talking about
images of boats I also went with their
boats
because she wanted to know my opinion on
I believe it's the Washington Community
no we have names brother
I'm sorry we have say that again brother
who's assisted that uh
that was sisters that's so nice thank
you Mr Parker
and I'm on your side but when I see a
football team changes names to
commanders you know I is I'm like you
know what is that are you insulted are
you feeling salted are you feeling
salted well Commander
he feels shaken up surely no no is it
the word Commander itself it doesn't
that suggest you know white supremacy
because most commanders around that time
were white and your name change it to
something that also is racist there is
no word
Egyptian pharaoh so you know give us
give us are you uh offended by all of
this or what I'm not a fit why would
that's the whole thing people are
offended by the name of the team I'm not
offended
listen you're okay I'm not black people
who want to actually pursue an injustice
from the past it's not a strange thing
it's not unusual it is not no no no no
no no no no no you can't conflate those
two things oh I'm doing it I am I am for
that okay
yes sir no no what she said is just
inaccurate she tried to conflate two
things she tried to say I didn't care
about the travesties and conflate that
with something about the football team
is going to change that no I agree with
you there are real issues that need to
be dealt with changing the football team
is basically not tackling the problem
exactly right it's a way to waste time
it's a way to waste a budget if if we if
we admit to and this is in cycle
analysis that there is such a thing as
generational trauma okay it does exist
it does exist in families and it can
exist in a people now I'm not going to
go all the way and say do this tear
statues down because I don't think
statues taking statute down solvers
anything you're going to go off to the
badges
if that isn't a racist term I don't know
maybe horses get offended here's my
point Paula everybody is offended by
everything and so once you agree with
you once you assume that we have to
start feeling guilty for our past there
is no end to it
I think the Irish
emotional terms
what I would love to do is have a
campaign to close down the guardian I
think it'll be hugely popular I think
because of their outlandish links to the
slave trade the guardian should fall on
their own virtue settling swords and
close themselves down as a matter if
they should cancel themselves so if
you're watching Guardian jealous I know
you probably are your guilty pleasure if
you're watching cancel yourselves
tonight and they'll do what you say it's
the right thing to do you are tarnished
by your slavery background and you must
end the Guardian newspaper as a matter
of urgency in the National interest and
then you can all run off and feel guilty
for the rest of your lives about the
shame do what you say on everybody and
when you're writing up your checkpies
you remind you how to spell my name I
know how to spell your name
first of all waiting for my check from
the Romans and the Vikings
aggressively pursuing uh
spirited debate as always and thank you
very much indeed over in America thank
you probably quite a good thing for you
you are several thousand miles away
because you're good they're beginning to
see him over I think you've got them
with the emotion line uh thank you both
uh all three of you very much indeed
well uncensored next protests very few
Street Parties by comparison to previous
Royal events and celebrities snubbing
the coronation even President Biden
staying away is the postlizabean crown
losing it Sparkle we'll debate that next
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
prime minister you're making the case
here now a MILF stands for mother I'd
like to I'm not going to say the next
word pop the kettle on this is the royal
tea did you keep quiet I'm trying to
read a book
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
you're thinking it
we're talking about
[Music]
thank you
very beloved letter
[Laughter]
this is like some kind of Submarine
prime minister you're making the case
here now a MILF stands for mother I'd
like to I'm not going to say the next
word pop the kettle on this is the royal
tea did you keep quiet I'm trying to
read a book
[Music]
thank you
we're just over two weeks until the
coronation of King Charles so it's the
country and the world in a group of
Royal fever well look quite when it
comes to Street parties sixteen thousand
were organized for the Queen's Platinum
Jubilee but there's only been 361
applications for the coronation this is
reflected in a new poll with 35 percent
of Brits saying they don't care very
much about it 29 saying they don't care
at all well nearly 1400 people expect to
take part in not my king protests world
leaders like President Biden and top pop
stars have also been snubbing the
coronation
um his the White House's press secretary
diplomatically trying to explain why
the president had about a 25 minute 30
minute call with the king king uh King
King Charles III and during which he
congratulated the king and they have a
very friendly uh conversation they have
a a good relationship with the King he
talked about uh how he enjoyed meeting
uh visiting uh the queen I should say
back in 2021 the king offered for him to
come and do a state a state visit which
which the president accepted and uh and
so they will see each other again very
soon and uh I'll just leave it there
you ever heard a lame lameer or more
tortured excuse for why the president of
the United States isn't coming so has
the crown lost its Shine by joining me
now as author and historian Tessa Dunlop
and King Charles is former Butler Grant
Harrell so welcome to both of you
um all right Tessa off you go has it
lost its luster the crown I think we've
maybe got royal ceremonial fatigue the
queen God bless I lived a very long time
so we had a golden chivalry we had a
Diamond Jubilee we had a platinum
Jubilee we had a thumper of a funeral
and now the airs come out of the machine
and you know because I missed you when
you're in America but I'm going to give
some of the blame to people like you and
people in the Press peddling this kind
of divisive narrative making the scars
and the royal family deeper than they
really did rather than the people doing
TV interviews and best-selling books
trashing the royal family who happen to
be members of the royal family they're
not to blame it's us reporting on the
trashing that's the problem that's a bit
like Prince Harry saying I never accused
the Royals of being racist even though
we all heard what him and Oprah him and
Meghan Markle told Oprah Winfrey no it
was the beastly media over two years
falsely reported it as racism until
we've now corrected them yes
that you haven't lost your
possess like the Atlanta
you work with Prince Charles no it's now
King Charles yeah
um I'm I'm excited by the coronation and
I think that the public probably will
come round quite quickly as they tend to
do for these things I think there'll be
a lot of further building up to the
coronation itself in that week and I
think we'll be surprised by this scale
actually celebrations for this it's the
first correlation of my lifetime in most
people's Lifetime with fast Carnation in
70 years and I've always said that with
the queen obviously we or most people
loved her we respected her as you
mentioned she had many jubilees and
celebrations this is a fuss for the king
you know it's a beginning film with his
new Reign and as you've said it takes
time but I think you know I know there's
in popularity pools and everything but
from the people I speak to people I know
a lot of people like Cameron myham
respect him
um but you're in the Royal bubbles those
peers you're in this I'm not in any
Royal bubble we are in a bit of a
cushion bubble where we hear all about
is drip fed into our inboxes oh this is
happening who's that chair's being
polished oh she's wearing that Crown
actually it's quite Satan but it is for
you I mean partly because it Butters
your bread and why not but but beyond
the sort of Central London chatterboxes
who's this really speaking to you know
in Europe can you tell me when the last
coronation was in Europe I don't care
well I care 1922 peers so what is
Britain doing still wandering around
with baubles in a cost of living crisis
I think that the app because actually
the molecule the molecule remains
something that the vast majority of this
country still respect and you can have
them on it like and have and I I think
the trouble is you see you being a key
supporter of the Duke and Duchess of
misrepresenting of whining what the
damage that they've done Grant I think
is actually quite calculable now well
you can see a lot of the reactions
especially in America I've just been a
lot of them saying yeah the trouble with
the Roses they're racist aren't they and
they're callous and they're horrible
because Harry says so I mean really
quite being quiet it's marked and
damaging it's certainly been uh
upsetting I mean I felt sorry for the
queen because obviously the entire life
this is what was all going on while
Philip was dying while she was dying
there's these two yapping away pouring
more and more money over them could you
imagine if it was a former staff member
doing it you know you'd be shy it just
wouldn't happen but can we be honest
Grant I bet you and Pierce certainly
peers if I know you even won Iota was
just an incy Wincy bit disappointed that
Megan isn't going to be at that car why
I I think I tell you why I'm
disappointed I'm very disappointed
Harry's going to be there I'm very
disappointed that Charles although I
completely understand it as a father why
he's felt the need to do this he doesn't
want to be seen to be the the bad guy in
the in the whole thing but what the hell
is Prince Harry doing having
I mean that that horrible book he wrote
the terrible series they've done the
interviews they've done trashing
trashing trashy trashing damaging the
institution of the monarchy damaging the
royal family and then they have the
brass neck he turns up at the coronation
we know that and we know why he's doing
it by the way we know why he's doing it
he's doing it because I suspect Meghan
Markle has gone you better get over
there and get on that balcony somehow
because our entire commercial World
depends on you still being a dominant
member of the royal family let's take a
let's take a reality check on the idea
of money in the commercial world when
today we've just seen it released after
comprehensive investigation by the
guardian the king is the richest royal
ever seen by World kind is it 1.8
billion pounds The Sovereign doesn't
have to pay inheritance tax you can feel
a bit of sympathy for Harry he's been
totally fine
Queen Charles that's where our national
wealth is they should be paying for the
coronation some money I'm sure is
Dunedin some of the wealth or something
um you know and I know you know you
could argue about the amount of money
they've got at the end of the day
I think they're good value as well I
think what he does
the tourism money that comes in alone
pays for the costs of us upkeeping the
royal family but if you got to hand your
Mansion to your children they could pay
for themselves they play by a different
set of rules which is why we judge yes
they do I mean and in return they live
in this endless goldfish Bowl they don't
have a lot of the freedoms that we enjoy
and have witnessed they do an
unbelievably large number of Duties a
year which by the way your two heroes
are in California they do zero they do
all they do is take their Royal titles
and sign massive contracts with
companies who only want them for one
thing to trash the family again which is
what they keep doing and that's my
argument against them but maybe the
bigger argument is if the coronation is
a bit paired down if it doesn't deliver
the Razzmatazz that some people expect
of it maybe that's the reality check we
go forward but with a pair down here but
the one thing this country the one thing
once we've gone through the in my I mean
I voted against it so I can say this
once we've gone through the ridiculous
faster brexit which is just clearly not
working and is actually damaging the
country or now how many years after it I
mean seven eight years after the vote
right so I don't see no evidence of this
thing working
um so we've become ever more insular and
people look at us and they see Boris
Johnson ridiculous this trust Ludacris
we become a laughing stock the one thing
that we do better than any other country
in the world is Pomp pageantry military
ceremony and we're putting the whole
shebang on in two weeks time and it's a
moment for the light of the world to
shine on my country and we can feel
proud about it rather than feeling
ashamed and embarrassed because Boris
has done something stupid again all this
trust is tank Global markets or whatever
it may be it appears if we want to feel
proud again then let's take away the
bile let's draw away the soap operas
Harry and Megan but no because we're
stoking we're not soaking in they're
doing it let's join together
Can't Ignore two members of the royal
family publicly trashing the royal
family it's obviously a huge news story
they've got to stop it can also see with
the coronation any big celebration with
royal family it brings people together
that's one thing I've noticed yeah
and also each year they've been in over
500 million from the tourist industry
can you imagine what they're been in
with the coronation weekend the amount
of people are going to be huge
absolutely great news is Harry goes home
after the show that is good news I've
kept my Sunday free for lunch with you
no the good news is he is going straight
home and that is his home his home now
is in Montecito in California a massive
mansion He got because he sold his
family out there's a word for that it's
called traitor anyway lovely to see you
again Tessa nice of you to make your
comeback on our show uh good to see you
too good to see you all the best
uncensored next how does comedy survive
in an age where just about everything is
offensive well comedian and Fox News
Star Captain this next she's written the
great book about this
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's just like some kind of Submarine
prime minister you're making the case
here now a MILF stands for mother I'd
like to I'm not going to say the next
word pop the kettle on this is the royal
tea did you keep quiet I'm trying to
read a book
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
you're thinking it we're talking about
babies
love it and let us Pride they're careful
who are you praying too this is like
some kind of Submarine prime minister
you're making the case here now a MILF
stands for mother I'd like to I'm not
going to say the next word pop the
kettle on this is the royal tea did you
keep quiet I'm trying to read a book
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to Piers Morganite Center
in the words of Ricky Gervais will
always be somebody offended by a joke
he's not wrong in a world where little
ships on football shirts are deemed
offensive and an almost endless list of
people products books Brands movies
ideas and dead historical figures have
all been canceled how is it possible to
still be funny woman s guest has some
ideas I'm joined by the comedian of Foxy
star Captain who has a new book out
called you can't joke about that cat
good evening to you good evening I love
this book I love everything about this
book because my God we need this book
what has happened to a world where in
America and Britain two of the greatest
democracies in history people are now
too scared to tell a joke in case they
literally get canceled
yeah and there is such this
misconception right that there's free
speech on the one side and then there's
sensitivity on the other side that's
really wrong because I mean I write in
my book about a lot of traumatic things
that I've been through and every single
one of those things was made worse by
the pressure that I could feel other
people felt to speak to me so carefully
and not say the wrong thing because then
in addition to dealing with something
traumatic like the death of my mother or
a medical situation that was very
serious I then also had to feel isolated
from other people who were terrified
around me and what actually did help me
was making jokes about those things that
you're really not supposed to joke about
because laughing at something is so
healing because it takes away its power
yes and it used to be the what they
called you know dark humor black humor
about things which is where you would
laugh sort of you know in serious
situations it used to be celebrate is a
kind of a well-known come foot blanket
to get through the difficulty in life
but now it's become a case where even in
your difficult moment someone says the
wrong thing they have to be canceled
therefore the whole thing gets even
worse
absolutely and I just don't know how
these are standards are put into place
to be sensitive to people going through
tough things because research shows that
you know everybody knows that you can't
make fun of for example a terminal
illness or make jokes about a terminal
illness except for the people who are
suffering from terminal illnesses who
rate humor as higher than solemnity and
what helps them to get through that and
feel better in in some cases even higher
than actual physical pain relief I know
when I was really struggling about this
in my book in Los Angeles I was alone I
was really broke uh things were going
really really bad for me and I started
doing stand-up comedy because I really
just felt so powerful over these things
that are making me feel powerless and
also being on stage and having people
laugh that became my only means of
connection really during the loneliest
time of my life and it's really really
sad to think that we might be losing
that well you talk I mean you talk with
unbelievable honesty and honestly it's a
fantastic look for that because it gives
it such a raw real quality about why
comedy became your savior in a way
because you went through so much and you
talk about grief and relationship
breakups and you know quite serious
illness all these things but the Common
Thread with all of it was that somehow
you found a way to laugh and you know
when I was young again in my family it
was also laughter's the best medicine
you know along with a large Scotch have
a laugh would be the Mantra but now it's
not like that too many people are like
well you can't you know as you say when
you're in a very awkward difficult sad
or whatever you know horrible situation
and she's the best way to lighten the
load but if you lose that the load never
gets lightened yes and also with every
tough thing that you go through the one
I suppose bright spot in that is by
going through it you're automatically
building a connection with everyone else
who's been that through that thing too
but what's the use if we can't talk
about it we can never make those
connections if we're too afraid to talk
about it and say how we really feel or
even make jokes about it that other
people might find healing and might make
those people feel less alone right I
mean I my mom as she was dying on her
deathbed knew she was dying she was
making jokes about it and I remember
looking at her and I remember learning
really even more than I already knew
okay if she can joke about her actual
there's nothing more serious than dying
right and if she can joke about that we
all can joke about anything well my
favorite joke when I grew up was what
was written on the hypochondriac's
tombstone told you I was Ill told you I
was Ill yeah which but then yeah that
was my favorite joke I love that joke
because it seemed to me just very funny
to me that's so normal because other
than being born the only thing we really
have in common is that we're all gonna
die yes and we just have really created
the wrong rules I think I think a lot
and the reception of this book has been
great I think a lot of people I've been
overwhelmed with the stories that I've
heard from people who say that this
resonated with them in one way or
another because I think a lot more
people really do feel this way but
they're afraid to say so yes and we that
we've wound up creating the wrong rules
in society where people are saying oh
you can't say that you can't joke about
that when really inside you know that
you can
but that's really hurting all of us
because we all kind of agree and have
more in common than we really would just
if we could just talk about it and joke
about it we'd all realize that we all
deep down do know it WG should there be
any limits I mean Ricky gervasi's view
is that once you start making exceptions
for anybody well then you never stop you
know it's a bit like the canceling of
historical figures or statues whatever
it may be once you start that path so it
with humor should everything be be on
limit for humor
yes I think that everything absolutely
and I think that actually the darker and
more traumatic something is the more
important it is to be able to make jokes
about that because what needs the
healing power of Comedy quite like the
dark stuff right and I mean I also
really feel like intention is the most
important thing intention with someone
intending to make you laugh and
entertain you or were they trying to be
hurtful on purpose there's this idiotic
school of thought out there now that if
someone says something is offensive
they're automatically right and it
doesn't matter whether they intended to
be offensive or not how could that
possibly be true it's not true when we
talk about murder or someone kills
someone on an accident versus planning a
murder how can we not have that same
standard for jokes it doesn't make any
sense and I think that if someone was
trying to make a joke and although you
might be hurt by it you should really be
measured in your reaction because not
only are you maybe setting up a standard
for yourself to get canceled you might
make other people afraid to make jokes
about other things that you might need
at some point in your life and Cat if I
just told you at 60 seconds to live and
obviously we both find that hilarious
given this conversation but if you're
saying what joke would you tell what
would be your last joke on Earth
I don't know what joke I would tell but
I would give the advice of if you are
someone who has lost a parent or a loved
one and people ask you about it and the
room gets all awkward and uncomfortable
like oh I'm so sorry you just say it's
okay you didn't kill her and then
everything the mood rebalances that's
something I learned losing my mom at a
relatively young age because I hate when
that it made it awkward and that made it
a lot easier for me and I'm really proud
of this book I'm very critical of myself
I hate almost everything I've ever done
but I feel like if I got hit by a bus
which I hope I don't I would be still
I've been life well lived because I feel
like this book is so important and I'm
very very proud of it it's it's a
fantastic book and because mainly
because you're so honest about yourself
and your life and why comedy's brutally
helps you you know yeah and it is it and
it's hilarious but you also make so many
great points in there and if you did get
hit by a bus rest assured I will be the
first to crack a joke thank you and I
would appreciate that I absolutely would
and yes I get brutally honest and
graphic because I want to make it so
clear that when I say you can joke about
everything I mean everything no matter
how embarrassing gross humiliating or
sad I'm giving you what with Greg
Gutfeld uh most nights you couldn't
really be any different because that of
course is exactly what he does right I
love when people say you're too mean to
cat over some intro that he does for me
that I actually wrote I saw that I love
that in the book that you write mostly
one-line singers about yourself you've
given him yeah I'm like I guess I'm a
good actress too because a lot of the
stuff that people have gotten mad at him
about I'm like okay I'm okay with it to
the point that I actually wrote it so
you don't need to get offended on my
behalf I think the problem's going to
come when very quickly probably tomorrow
he's gonna have to start introducing you
as a number one best-selling author it's
gonna eat him alive uh cat it's a
brilliant book you can't joke about that
why everything is funny nothing is
sacred and we're all in this together
thank you for writing this we need this
kind of book in in society today so good
luck with it and I hope you are number
one and I want to see Greg's face when
you are thank you so much
well I'm says the next Deputy Prime
Minister Dominic Robb is clinging to his
job over bullying allegations should he
be fire we'll talk to someone who claims
to be one of the victims of his bullying
next
[Music]
thank you
very beloved and let us bright so
careful who are you trying to exactly
it's just like some kind of Submarine
prime minister you're making the case
here now a MILF stands for mother I'd
like to I'm not going to say the next
word pop the kettle on this is the royal
tea did you keep quiet I'm trying to
read a book
[Music]
thank you
all right
[Music]
foreign
this is
really beloved and let us bright
they're careful we've been praying too
exactly this is like some kind of
Submarine prime minister you're making
the case here now a MILF stands for
mother I'd like to I'm not going to say
the next word pop the kettle on this is
the royal tea
keep quiet I'm trying to read a book
[Music]
coming up on the talk tonight Fergie
comes out in defense of her ex-husband
prince Andrew saying we should give the
disgrace Duke a break the fate of
Dominic Robb hangs in the balance
tonight especially soon like Dithers
over the reporting to his alleged bully
and campaigners want to cancel
Manchester United and Manchester City's
football badges over slavery leagues
that's all at nine o'clock with this
shower
no here's a shower too well some
breaking news has been reported that
charges against the actor Alec Baldwin
all the criminal charges over the fatal
shooting of Helena Hutchins on the film
rust have just been dropped
extraordinary development has come to
ours was announced the production of the
movie is now resuming with her husband
the late Helena's husband taking on the
role of executive producer so that's
breaking news tonight I'm joined by talk
to these International editor Isabel oh
sure talk to your presenter Richard Tice
and campaign leader of the true and fair
party Gina Miller well welcome to all of
you a superstar pack if ever there was
one uh Gina so I want to start with you
because Dominic Raab his future hangs in
the balance uh this report into whether
he's a big bully has gone to number 10
rich assume that I can spend hours going
through it no decision or announcement
based on what he's been reading today so
we expect it tomorrow you yourself had
experience with Rob which makes you
think he is a bully well they they're
two different things I've had personal
experience where he was a bully to me
but this is in what way in so I was um
doing a morning today program about
um the case that I bought my first case
and in coming down from the show in the
lift he basically called me names
um like
um it can't work out if you're just a
silly or um if you are really rich
or if you've got or you're just naive he
called you a silly or if I was
naively wrong called you a silly
but after that as well when we next met
another occasion when we were on um we
were going to another question time show
whatever and you know he then his
behavior was inappropriate as well on
that occasion in my way and I've written
so I was on the show I was going to be
there with Nish Kumar the comedian who
was on my brother was there and and RAB
sort of went up to my brother who looks
nothing like Niche and said to him oh
we're on together and totally ignored me
and said we're on the show together this
evening my brother said no I'm not
um you know we don't look all the same
and Brad sort of looked really
embarrassing came out and he said well
why didn't you say hello to Gina Miller
you're on the show she's on the panel
with us tonight and he just looked at me
and walked off and it was just a bizarre
way of Behaving I mean that's sort of
weird inappropriate the first thing he
said yeah if Dominic Rob who's Deputy
Prime Minister called you a sister well
he wasn't that and obviously he is now
he wasn't he is now but but if but I
would I was going to say is it's
different is this Behavior that's going
on this this report is about him being a
boss across not one but three Department
government departments yeah but if
that's the way he spoke to a
high-profile woman at the time privately
when he doesn't think people are
watching but the thing is I think it's
because he saw me as being lesser than
himself yeah I think that's why okay
okay let me bring in Isabel because I
think you came here to be defensive of
it but when you hear that as a woman
what do you think is it's not even as a
woman I'm just actually shocked so I
mean I've known Dominic Robb since 2010
since he first came in as a back bench
newly elected toy MP I have never found
him anything other than at the very
least civil I think he's a got a very
very strong work ethic he is a
workaholic I think he demands very high
standards of himself and the people who
work for him and I strongly suspect that
that results in him sometimes being
quite what do you feel now you've heard
he's quite demanding so I was absolutely
going to defend him on that basis if he
said that that is but you can also don't
worry about how he wrote about me as
well and talked about me yeah but that
particular line I mean it's too tired
should anyone be Deputy Prime Minister
who calls women silly I mean
that is indefensible that's obviously
the first I've heard of it truly
shocking and one would like to say
frankly no I mean that's just an
extraordinary way to carry on with
anybody and what it makes me think I've
always looked at work I just thought he
always looked permanently angry and has
one of those mean faces that's not
enough to judge him or convict him but
I've always none of it surprises me I
mean he looks cheerful they've been a
creepy kind of animal lecture way but
for the but what what Jesus just told me
I can quite believe that no it's because
of my instinct about him I can't believe
anybody yes it's because he didn't get
it he was angry he was yeah but he
doesn't matter it doesn't matter what it
shows me because what it shows me is
he's perfectly capable of doing that to
you but this is capable of any of these
things
say anything about it at the time I mean
that's quite a big story no no because I
was being battled no I was being
attacked from just about everywhere for
for the case the last thing I wanted to
do was bring more attention onto myself
and at the time I was so stunned when
the doors opened yeah um and uh you came
out the lifts I actually couldn't
believe somebody had actually just
spoken to me this was at the BBC yeah I
was coming down and left after the today
program what did you say to him I I
didn't say anything because my car came
the runner came up and and sort of said
your car is here Mrs Miller and I went
off
and in the way no no in the way and the
reason I know that is because I bought
this thing a weird habit I write things
down and so I actually have the diary
from wow the time where I wrote it down
have you ever talked about this before
well not not work but but also no I did
do an article in the independent they
checked and I they've got my they saw my
entry you didn't include that that
particular I said I said that he not
that spectacular phrasing but I mean I
gotta say that that to me is a big
development because it shows to me he's
this is a guy who talks to women like
you like that that's pretty shocking
yeah I mean I want ministers to be
demanding of civil servants to get
performance so they're held to account
and they deliver for taxpayers who pay
their salaries but we do not want
ministers behaving like that frankly
with anybody but what I'm saying is this
is is this somebody who which plays into
what peers is saying is about this is
somebody who when it's Juniors or maybe
some people he doesn't see us being on
the same level as himself has a
sustained pattern of behavior it says to
me it's just a nasty busy working a
bully which is bullying so therefore it
makes me think that I mean let's see
what the report says but there's so many
people have very similar stories it's
like eventually you know
can he really be an innocent guy when we
just said that well I think snack's got
a real problem because the thing is if
he if he says no um you know rap stays
there's a whole load of civil servants
who are saying that they're going to
walk and they could bring individual
cases against rap so this is not over
well I think we should obviously see how
it all goes but then maybe reconvene
afterwards maybe next week because it's
going to be a big story uh we've
actually run out of talking but this was
such a enthralling development to run
out of time what we have got time for is
today a very exciting development on
here's Morgan uncensored in less than a
year it's our first anniversary next
week we have passed 1 million
subscribers to our YouTube channel which
is making us apparently the fastest
growing news interview show not just in
this country but anywhere in the world
so thank you if you're one of our
subscribers there's the live thing there
if you're not one get on our YouTube
channel subscribe all our great
interviews are there all the great
contents here and we have this wonderful
cake here which has been done especially
for us here it is where's Camera one
there we are Piers Morgan uncensored 1
million subscribers absolutely brilliant
thanks to my brilliant digital team
who've led the way to Lindsay and Matty
he's done a great job thanks to all the
piers censor teams but getting us all
the great content thanks to my great
pack
happy happy anniversary next week
congratulations to us we're all
wonderful
[Music]
very beloved let us Pride be careful who
are you trying to exactly it's just like
some kind of Submarine prime minister
you're making the case here now a MILF
stands for mother I'd like to I'm not
going to say the next word pop the
kettle on this is the royal tea did you
keep quiet I'm trying to read
hahaha
[Music]
foreign